spectacle depuis que rené goscinny et
albert uderzo on inventait astérix et
obélix et de gaulois sont véritablement
devenu l'image symbole des français
remplaçant ainsi le béret basque et la
baguette de pain sous le bras
personnage de bande dessinée vendus à
des dizaines de millions d'exemplaires
avant de devenir des héros de dessin
animé
il se retrouve aujourd'hui en chair et
en os au cirque d'hiver à paris en
compagnie de tout leur petit monde 40
comédiens cascadeurs un chien quatre
sangliers quatre chevaux un éléphant des
poules et des canards
tous habitants de ce petit village qui
n'accepte pas la domination romaine
obélix et astérix sur scène c'est un
pari que tant de jérôme savary
nicole corner langlois claude sicard qui
sont fous ces gaulois ils viennent
d'installer leur village au point de
chaume au cirque d'hiver
avec leurs chansons dans ces bagarres
ils font exploser la bande dessinée les
cohortes de romain stupide et paresseux
des fils tandis que les gaulois à eux
pour la fête
aidés par leurs pressions célèbre et un
orchestre contemporain
ricks ashkan onyx obélix et les autres
existent grâce au talent d'un magicien
vigilant 3 être vraiment rester très
fidèle à la bd ce que je peux dire c'est
que peut-être que la bd est un peu
savent aryenne faut pas oublier que
goscinny a été le père spirituel de
toute une génération qui est la mienne
la génération des sixties comme on dit
les gotlib les réserves les les wolinski
et et finalement je me retrouve dans
dans l'humour de goscinny je n'ai donc
pas eu vraiment besoin de vraiment
besoin de rajouter quoi que ce soit je
pense que 90% du texte du spectacle
astérix et du texte original de goscinny
de toutes les bandes dessinées que je
connais c'est celle qui me semble la
plus apte à pellets en même temps aux
enfants et aux adultes et j'adore
rien de spécial non rien nouveau ah si
j'oubliais j'ai assommé une patrouille
romaine dans la clairière des carmes ou
pas bon tu viens manger le sens bien
avec moi je reviens dans quelques
instants
j'ai encore du menhir libre une cd
j'ai pas formidable
ah ah
on veut pas parler
simple et drôle pour les enfants le
spectacle devient sophistiqués pour les
adultes